هذا وقال سيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان قوات
الروسيه لم تكن مستعده لعواقب
تفجيرت خسائر في القوات والاسلحه والذخائر
حسب قولها واضافه ان تفجير السد ادى لمقتل
وجرحي وفقدان عدد من افراد وحدات فرقه
الهجوم المحموله جوا وفيلق الجيش الثاني
والعشرين الروسيه
نذهب الى مراسلينا من كوليف مراسلنا حسام
مسعود الوضع على الارض اليوم بعد مرور هذه
الساعات على تفجير سد كخوفكا
التصريحات الرسميه توضح الواقعه في خرسون
اليوم والتي صدرت بشكل رئيسي عن الاداره
العسكريه في المنطقه والتي تشير الى ارقام
مهمه في الحقيقه بدايه تشير الى منسوب
ارتفاع المياه الذي وصل الى 5.6 امتار
بالمعدل هذا يعني ان هناك مناطق تبلغ يبلغ
ارتفاع المياه فيها اكثر من 5.6 امتار
وغيرها من المناطق التي تبلغ فيها ارتفاع
المياه ارتفاع اقل من ذلك ولكن وفق ما
رايناه هناك يبدو ان المياه ما زالت
بارتفاع يوم امس كانت التصريحات الرسميه
تشير الى اربعه امتار فقط ولكن اليوم
نتحدث عن ارتفاع اكثر من ذلك هذا فيما
يرتبط بارتفاع المياه اما ايضا حول
الخسائر في منطقه خرسون الاداره العسكريه
المواليه لاوكرانيا حقيقه اشارت الى ارقام
مهمه على الضفتين
اخرى بعد ما كنا قد تمكنا بالدخول اليها
خلال اليوم الماضي اما على المستوى الاخر
وهو المستوى المرتبط بالميدان
وخصوصا ان هذه الحادثه ليست حادثه طبيعيه
فقط حدثت في اوكرانيا او امر جرى بسبب
عوامل
الطبيعه انما ما جرى وكان تفجير كما تقول
اوكرانيا انه تفجير متعمد تصر الروايه
الاوكرانيه ان من قام بذلك هو الجانب
الروسي لكن في ذات الوقت هناك تصريحات
للمتحدثه باسم قياده عمليات الجنوب التي
اشارت الى ان الجانب الروسي لم يكن مستعدا
لعواقب هذا التفجير وما حدث ان عدد من
الوحدات في مجموعات قتاليه هجوميه تحديدا
من اللواء محمول جوا تضررت بشكل كبير
تحدثت عن قتلى وجرحى او مصابين بالاضافه
الى عدد من المفقودين من الجانب الروسي
جراء هذا التفجير كما اكدت كذلك ان الجانب
الروسي اضطر بعد هذا التفجير للتراجع الى
مسافه تبلغ بين خمسه كيلومترات وخمسه عشره
كيلو مترا وهذا
اثر على الواقع الميداني العسكري في منطقه
خرسون بين الجبهتين وفي ذات الوقت ايضا
هذا الامر كما قالت اثر على حجم وكثافه
القصف باتجاه منطقه خرسون قالت ان القصف
مستمر عمده المدينه تحدث عن 35 عمليه قصف
خلال الساعات الماضيه حتى في ظل هذه
الكارثه التي يعاني منها الجانبين في
الحقيقه وفي ذات الوقت ايضا
تحدثت عن ان القوات الروسيه خسرت الكثير
من المناطق والمستودعات الخاصه بالذخيره
ومواقع التي كانت تتمركز بها والخنادق
التي كانت قد حفلتها وهو ايضا ما يشير الى
الخسائر الكبيره عند الجانب الذي تسيطر
عليه القوات الروسيه اكثر منه من الجانب
الذي سيطر عليه القوات الاوكرانيه